patrick henry est âgé aujourd'hui de 47
ans il a donc passé plus de la moitié de
sa vie en prison on pourrait même dire
qu'il a vécu deux vies celle du preneur
d'otages qui demandent une rançon après
avoir tué un enfant de sept ans après sa
condamnation en revanche et après avoir
échappé à la peine de mort
il a entamé une rédemption par les
études et il est devenu un prisonnier
exemplaires pierre nicolas
c'est à la sortie de cette école que
disparaît en janvier 1976 philippe
bertrand sept ans dans le pavillon de
ses parents quelques minutes plus tard
le téléphone sonne
l'enfant sera rendue contre une rançon
d'un million de francs après plusieurs
jours d'une enquête infructueuses la
famille lance un appel désespéré au
ravisseur les enquêteurs soupçonnent un
proche de la famille patrick henry un
jeune représentant de commerce endettés
qui nie être liés à l'enlèvement avec un
cynisme effroyable
bien sûr il ya eu des gants incidence
qui ont qui ont fait que d'ailleurs pose
c'est pourquoi la police s'est adressé à
moi c'est les coïncidences et quelle a
été votre sortie bordeaux entendez
stappert écouter ça fait plutôt ça fait
mal au coeur pour les parents et puis
surtout pour le petit garçon est
évidemment on souhaite un dénouement
très rapide et heureux de cette affaire
interviewé par une radio patrick henry
va même plus loin dans la provocation
je pense que c'est oui c'est tout le
pays patrick henry mentait c'était bien
lui qui avait enlevé puis être anglais
le petit philippe bertrand
il sera retrouvé sous un lit dans une
chambre d'hôtel sordides les premiers à
condamner l'assassin sont ses parents
nous personnellement on perd un garçon
de 3 ans mais déjà des gens perdent
ainsi gosse de 10 ans qui est beaucoup
plus terrible est à l'heure que même
s'il était condamné à mort pour le
comprendre il
c'est normal moi j'estime que la
condamnation à mort est là juste
punition de ce qu'il a fait au moment du
procès la foule réclame la tête de celui
qui a dupé tout le monde mais un avocat
de grand talent robert badinter lui
évite la peine capitale condamné à
perpétuité patrick henry vient de passer
la moitié de sa vie en prison en juillet
dernier lisabeth guigou avait refusé la
libération conditionnelle de cet
assassin qui à lui seul poste depuis des
années cette question lancinante à tout
un pays
à partir de quand la dangerosité d'un
criminel est à l'effacer par une peine
d'emprisonnement
au point de le relâcher
[Musique]